dozens of rescue teams are working
around the clock to reach 10 miners
trapped underground since Tuesday
the operation is challenging because
workers are about 900 meters below and
the mine is connected to five others
two miners were rescued earlier
at around 8 15 PM we heard a strong
blast and then it triggered as if it
were an earthquake at that moment we
left and we saw the mine entries
ejecting smoke and dust
the explosion at this Coal Mine in
central Colombia is being blamed on a
buildup of
me gas
ambulances and families of the Trap
miners have surrounded the accident side
in sutata USA
I don't think my son is alive
my heart says he isn't
I wish he is but I don't think so I
don't think he's in this world because
after a blast that's difficult only a
miracle
at least 130 000 people make a living
from mining in Colombia and unions for a
long time have been calling on the
government to improve working conditions